to do this uh james there's got to be
somebody that pissed you off right i
mean to do this there's got to be
somebody that either offended you or
uh uh you know because i looked at your
parents they were conservative but not
at the levels that you are you know i
kind of saw what their beliefs were they
were they were leaning right as well
but did somebody offend you did somebody
upset you used to be a writer at your
school and then you went and decided to
start your own paper instead of write i
think was called centurion i don't know
what it was maybe it was called
so so it's not like you know
what was the one event i mean maybe even
we can go back to high school if you and
i were in 10th grade 11th grade
who was james o'keefe that's a great
question um
uh
i can answer it in two different ways by
talking about that but i think as a
teenager i remember being young young
man and and certainly in college i read
i was very fascinated by journalism i
would read the newspaper every day new
york times i i
love and star ledger i'm from new jersey
so that's i don't even know 10th grade
you were reading the new york times i
mean he went to rutgers so this guy's
been well in college particularly i was
obsessed with reading the newspaper now
this is 20 years ago and or 19 years ago
and these newspapers are becoming a
shell of themselves they're basically
like you know exit skeleton they throw
ap articles in there but this star they
provided a free copy in college uh at
rutgers public university in new jersey
of the star ledger us today new york
times i would sit there in the dining
hall every morning because i was a shy
introverted kid and i had no friends my
freshman year and i would read front to
back all those three papers and i
considered that my education i was a
philosophy major but i would i was
religious about reading the news and i
was fascinated by it
as a teenager i don't know maybe
13 14 years old i would i would watch
local news so i grew up in the new york
city suburbs of new jersey and i would
watch the
broadcast and just i just felt
intuitively
that how they were portraying things
were not as things were so
things were not portrayed as they were
and rarely as they ought to be and
that's the best way i can describe it
it's just sort of a
and i know everyone knows what i'm
talking about because now it's
self-evident the news is not showing you
how things actually are
they're describing reality and it
affected me i remember i remember it
affecting me and i didn't know i was
ever going to do anything about it i
didn't i didn't think that i'm going to
be a journalist i didn't even know
frankly what a journalist was or what a
journalist did and i certainly had no
inclination of going to journalism
school
and i was in boy scouts i was a an eagle
scout actually and when i was about 18
years old they had this board of review
conference where you go before your
scout master
and
they asked me what do you want to do
with your life
and i went on this rant about things
because i was trying to look for
guidance
and uh and he said and i said i said
things are not what they seem and and
and rarely as they should be
and he said have you ever thought about
going into journalism
and that was the first time anybody ever
said that to me and i and i thought
about that and i didn't know what it
meant to be a journalist and then i went
to college and i read these papers every
day and i was literally reading the new
york times run to back and i got angry
at the new york times
i said that's not right that doesn't
seem you know this is right after 9 11
and the world events that were happening
and the op-ed pages
so i decided to um uh write a column for
what was the daily rutgers newspaper the
daily targum it was called and i wrote a
column and i started
and then i researched how the ratio
of democrats to republicans of the
professors at the university and the
ratio was a hundred and four to one the
imbalance of it and the imbalance of it
affected me too and i said well that's
not right there should be more
ideological balance among the faculty
and and then we can talk more about what
happened next but that was the the
initial origins so the reason why i
asked that is you know adam you know
he's
been a comedian before and then from
there he went into business and has done
well for himself you know when you think
about comedians you'll typically the dna
of a comedian is a what somebody that
maybe lived a rough life so humor was a
way of you know just what's the
word or where to go
a lot of comedians have dealt with
issues oh yeah tremendous of course yeah
so then you you think about like ufc
fighters like gsp or some of these other
guys their
lineage to wanting to become great
fighters was what they were bullied as a
kid so there was a form of
them being bullied bodybuilders same
thing
what what did somebody piss you off did
somebody bully you or did somebody did
you live a rough life did you see
somebody right in front of your eyes
betray somebody and lie and they went to
jail or something happened to them he
said i just don't think this is right
good question i remind you a question i
think was canada someone's asked me what
happened to you or maybe it wasn't her
but someone said something someone did
something why does that question keep
popping up though no it's actually only
the second time i've been asked the
question and i and i'm not a
psychologist i i but let me attempt to
answer it um the only thing i can say
about my childhood
before this teenager watching local you
know fox5 new york news was
my grandfather and father i was raised i
did have an unusual upbringing in the
sense that i was doing property
maintenance with my my father and
grandfather i'm the third james o'keefe
iii my grandfather um would wake me up
in the morning and we'd go do what work
on the houses every morning paint and
and landscape and do roofing and
plumbing work and
i guess it it was looking back it's like
kind of like a child uh slave labor i
don't resent it i think it's it's it was
formative and taught me values and hard
work but i did not like the work um i
never took to it
and we would work all weekend and every
night during school
and and we we you know i told this story
before but since you asked um
you know that was very formative for me
it was a sort of indefatigability that
my grandfather and father instilled in
me very tunnel vision so we would work
on these homes doing everything
ourselves we didn't hire any labor
and for years starting at five years old
i would i would do manual labor with my
father and grandfather every weekend
dirty disgusting work and they didn't
make small talk with me
my father never never did i wanted to
but we never made small talk we just
work work work work work and and i hated
doing the work i i just tested it i'm a
very creative person i always have felt
that
and i would daydream during the work and
i would think about things but i was
forced to do this
so my only and i'm not a psychologist
i'm speculating here but i i suppose
that
they instilled in me something i
didn't necessarily have when i was born
which is this
tunnel visioned almost maniacal drive
although they gave me that
but my my passion was different than
you know you know pvc pipes and and uh
roofing my passion was we was exposing
and artistic so when you combine those
two things but i don't no one ever
really pissed me off it was more just
the hard work that i did that i guess
instilled in me so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]